Prof: So,
what I want to do today is
resist the temptation to talk
about anarchism the entire time.
I sent around the terms for
today of which I only forgot one
or two.
What I think I'll do at the
beginning is I'm going to talk
very quickly about socialism,
and the difference between
revolutionary socialism and
reform socialism.
Add syndicalism to the mix,
and these are all terms that I
sent to you, so I'm not going to
write them on the board,
because I need the board.
Then for most of the lecture
I'm going to talk about
anarchism.
Anarchists didn't want to
reform the state.
They didn't want to seize
control of the state either by
revolution or by electoral
process.
They wanted to destroy the
state.
So, I'm going to talk about
those guys for a while.
Most anarchists were not
terrorists,
but at the end I'm going to
talk about a guy that I followed
around for four or five years
who was a terrorist,
and arguably--it's a book I
just finished--one can find the
origins of modern terrorism in
this guy,
who is called Émile
Henry.
This will fit into Paris.
It's obviously sort of a
sub-theme in this course,
and so is the state and
capitalism.
This particular person,
Émile Henry,
set out to bomb and to kill.
His targets changed the name of
the game for terrorists.
That's obviously what I can't
wait to talk about.
But first I'm going to just
review briefly for you,
it's getting briefer every
second that I think about this,
the socialist stuff,
which you can read about.
With the rise of mass politics
in Europe in the 1880s and
1890s, there was the rise of
mass socialist parties.
Basically just to review:
there are two kinds of
socialism.
There were the revolutionary
socialists,
of which Marx was an obvious
example and his son-in-law Paul
Lafargue,
a name you don't have to
retain,
who brought Marxist theory to
France,
who believed that revolution
would come when the proletariat
was class-conscious and after a
bourgeois revolution,
of which he basically thought
1848 had been a good example
following in 1789.
And the proletariat would rise
up and break their chains and
bring this brave new world.
And, so, there were
revolutionary socialists in
Italy, in Spain,
and in France,
and even a few in Germany.
Reform socialists said,
"Look, states are becoming
stronger and stronger,
and can break revolutions very
easily.
Look what happened to the Paris
Commune of 1871 when about
25,000 people are massacred,
men,
women and children are gunned
down,
and that the way to bringing
social reform and abolishing the
abuses of capitalism is through
reform."
This is the reformist tradition
in Germany.
It's identified with somebody
who's in the book,
Edouard Bernstein.
And you can see this in the
growth of the SPD,
the German Socialist Reformist
Party,
which was the largest party in
the Reichstag in 1914 when war
breaks out.
What you do is if you organize,
you can--legislatures,
if you have enough socialists
and enough well-meaning other
people in the legislatures,
in the Reichstag,
or in the Chambre des
Députés,
or the other parliaments in
places that had parliaments,
then you can vote in laws.
You can vote in mine safety
regulations, because mining
accidents killed so many people.
There's one in the Pas de
Calais where hundreds and
hundreds of people,
a thousand people get killed in
one accident in about 1910 or
1911.
You can pass an eight-hour day
or a ten-hour day.
You can pass laws making it
harder and harder to employ
children, particularly in
dangerous tasks.
You can do things for women.
You could do things for
families.
If you elect the right kind of
people, you can have a
revolution through reform,
through the ballot.
And the great socialist leaders
such as Bernstein,
whom I just mentioned,
or the great Jean
Jaurès,
whose death on the 31^(st) of
July in 1914 was really the end
of an era and the beginning of
another era,
a scary era of the war--people
had that sense.
He was the one who in France
unified the reform socialists
and the revolutionary
socialists, though there are
still fissures in their
approaches.
Of course, the old
revolutionary socialists would
become the Communists after
1920,
when the French Communist Party
is begun in the wake of the
Russian Revolution,
which seemed to be,
even though it was a revolution
in a very complex situation,
that seemed to say that you can
have a revolution.
But anyway, reform socialists
dominate in Germany.
They dominate in France.
They dominate in Belgium.
The Socialist Party is terribly
important in Italy;
they become more important in
Spain as well.
Those are the two big
traditions.
Some of the tensions between
revolutionary socialists and
reform socialists can be seen in
the fact that revolutionary
socialists said,
"Look,
if you are working in the
Reichstag and you're trying to
get better insurance
plans," ironically it was
Bismarck's Germany that gives
really the first substantial
insurance program for workers,
"what you're doing is
you're propping up the bourgeois
state.
You're buying into it.
You're supporting indirectly
their armies that crush workers
and strikes,"
and they did in the heroic age
of syndicalism,
but more about that in a
minute,
1895 to about 1907 in France.
But in other countries it's
about the same thing.
"You're propping up the
bourgeois state by participating
in electoral politics."
But lots of revolutionary
socialists,
and this is all in the book so
don't worry about this,
but a lot of them say,
"Look,
if we don't run candidates and
elections,
how are they going to know
about us?"
So, they, too,
would run candidates and
elections.
So, they're put at really kind
of coincé.
They're really sort of stuck
between a rock and a hard place,
because they're running
candidates in elections in which
they do not believe.
I'm not here talking about
Russia,
because that is more
complicated with the Bolsheviks,
and the Mensheviks,
and the socialist
revolutionaries,
and we will come back to them.
I'm talking basically about
Western Europe.
You have to imagine that Lenin
and the other Russian socialists
are sort of walking around the
lakes of Geneva and of Zurich in
exile and trying to imagine this
future.
But that's the big difference
between socialists,
reform and revolutionary.
Now, to make things even more
complicated, you have a group
called the syndicalists.
The word
"syndicalist"
is an English word which I sent
along on your friendly email
from yours truly.
Syndicalist,
the word comes from the French
word for unions,
which is a syndicat.
What they said is,
"Hang on."
They kind of believed with the
revolutionary socialists,
saying,
"If you get involved in
electoral process,
you are propping up this
corrupt bourgeois state.
You are propping up this
dynamic duo of the state and
capitalism."
Syndicalists say,
"Look, we will organize
from the ground up,
beginning in the shop floor,
the factory.
That will be not only a means
to obtain a revolution,
it's a way of seeing what the
future world will be like when
everybody tutoies
everybody or Dus
everybody.
The kind of relations,
the friendly equal relations of
the shop floor become,
after the revolution,
the way the world will be
organized."
In the South of Europe,
in Italy and in Spain,
these folks are called,
and I sent this around to you,
anarcho-syndicalists.
You see a transition here.
Anarcho-syndicalists.
Because they're rejecting the
state and they're looking in the
future, the decentralized
organization is part of it.
Anarcho-syndicalists have
considerable influence in Spain
and Italy.
They believe in direct action,
and sabotage,
and strikes,
but in union organization.
One of the most interesting--I
mention him in the book--Fernand
Pelloutier,
who wrote a book called The
Dying Society,
was one of the theoreticians of
anarcho-syndicalism,
of syndicalism.
He was dying.
He was dying of TB.
Though he was not a worker,
tuberculosis was a
working-class disease.
Go to Pennsylvania.
Go to West Virginia.
Tuberculosis,
the ravages of the mines in the
United States,
were just incredible.
In porcelain factories and all
sorts of places,
glass factories all over the
place.
Pelloutier creates these things
called labor exchanges.
He's one of the people who come
to these things called labor
exchanges,
bourse de travail,
you call them in French,
which were towns where you had
municipal socialists in power at
the municipal level--and you
did,
in some cities,
are giving municipal funds to
start these labor exchanges
which are buildings.
You can still see them.
When I was invited to Limoges
to give a big talk by the
Conféderation
Général du
Travail,
we started the
apéro,
the first round of drinks,
about noon in the labor
exchange,
in the maison du peuple,
the house of the people.
They were places where workers
coming from other places could
come and get a meal,
get some money and,
above all, find out about jobs.
So, syndicalists--the way they
imagine the future,
and preparing for this brave
new world of post-revolutionary
relationships,
that has an important
privileged place in the way they
view the world.
There was an engineer called
Georges Sorel,
whose name I should have send
around, S-O-R-E-L.
He comes to the notion of the
general strike.
One day all workers will simply
put down their tools and say,
"Hell with you,
capitalism.
Hell with you, the State.
And they will bring capitalism
to its knees."
It doesn't really ever work out
that way, does it?
The capitalists and the State
win the day.
So, having rushed through all
of that, let me talk about what
I want to talk about.
That is anarchism,
of which there is only a couple
short, and I hope sprightly,
paragraphs in which you're
reading.
I am not an anarchist.
Sometimes when I give talks at
various places--I was at St.
Louis recently,
and other places,
people at the end will
think--hopefully,
they'll never think I'm a
terrorist,
because I'm certainly not,
and when I talk about this guy
I do not do so with affection or
admiration.
But I know him because I
followed him around.
I followed him around.
Most anarchists were not
terrorists.
One wants to make that clear.
It's not surprising that the
great strengths of anarchism are
in Spain in Catalonia and in
Andalusia in the south of Spain
and in southern Italy.
Why?
Because that's where the
Italian and the Spanish states
have very limited success in
convincing people that they're
Spanish or Italian.
Why should they believe they're
Spanish or Italian?
Southern Italians thought that
the republic was a monarchy.
But the progressive monarchy,
so called, was a plot launched
by tax collectors and industrial
capitalists in the North of
Italy.
In Andalusia and in Catalonia
were the Civil Guard,
who tended to be from Galicia,
a conservative part of Spain
where the odious Franco was from
or from Castile,
a huge area around Madrid.
It was easy to see how they
associated the state with
something that they didn't want.
In writing about anarchism,
I tried to put myself and tried
to think of how anarchists
viewed the world.
I want to tell you a story
that's a true story.
If you're trying to imagine how
anarchists viewed the world,
this story is not a bad one.
It's about a cork worker making
corks for bottles of sherry in
the south of Spain.
He's dying.
He'd been an anarchist his
entire life.
He hated the state.
He hated capitalism.
He hated the church.
He's dying.
He's on his deathbed.
He had married a woman from a
religiously practicing Catholic
family.
In the scene in this room in
which he's dying,
in one part of the room is his
family,
who hated organized religion,
who view it as a prop for
capitalism and the state.
On the other side of the room
are people who are not so sure.
They went to church sometimes.
They knew the priest.
When he's lying there,
the end is near.
His wife's family says,
"Pedro,
don't you want me to bring a
lawyer in?
A lawyer who will take your
last will."
Anarchists don't have wills and
they don't have very much
property.
The other side of the room is
just utter terror,
horror.
How can they suggest such a
thing, that Pedro is going to
make a will?
That's a bourgeois thing to do,
to make a will.
Then somebody else from his
wife's family says,
"Pedro,
the end is near.
Don't you want us to get a
priest for the last
rights?"
He'd never set foot in a church
and proudly so.
Consternation on the other side
of the room.
How will it all end?
How will Pedro end his life?
With a lawyer and a priest?
So, Pedro looks up and he says,
"Go and get me a lawyer.
Bring me a lawyer."
Then he says,
"Go and tell father,"
the priest, "to come to
see me."
Joy--utter consternation.
Pedro's lying in a bed in the
middle.
So, pretty soon the lawyer
comes dressed in his little
suit.
He doesn't yet have a
calculator to tote up the bill,
but he's got his legal pad.
He's never been in that house
before.
He comes down by the bed and he
says, "Pedro,
you have a few possessions,
a fork, a knife,
a couple of plates.
Don't you want to give me your
will now?"
Pedro says, "Wait a minute.
Wait a minute,
señor.
Wait a minute."
Then the priest comes.
He has his purple--I remember
this from Jesuit high school
days--thing that they wear on
Easter.
He has his little case also,
which he has the holy oil to
bless Pedro and give him the
last rights.
He comes close and he says,
"Pedro,
the end is near.
You've led a good life,
but I haven't seen you in
church very much or ever,
for that matter.
Your children are not baptized.
Don't you want to make a
confession?
You're going to meet your maker
soon.
Don't you want to make a
confession to me right now?
Nobody can hear you.
Don't you have something you
want to tell me?
Isn't there something you can
tell me?"
Consternation on one side,
silent joy on the other.
Pedro says to the lawyer,
"Come here,
señor.
I want you to stand on the left
side of my bed."
He says to the priest,
"Father,
come here please.
I want you to stand on the
right side of my bed."
Then he smiles a smile of utter
contempt.
He says, "Now you can all
see both sides of the family.
Like Christ,
I am dying between two
thieves."
And he died.
To imagine the kind of hate
that anarchists had of soldiers,
and priests,
and of officials,
and of Castilian Guardia Civil,
that was how anarchism was born.
When was anarchism born?
There's a couple antecedents in
the eighteenth century,
but they're terribly irrelevant
people that hardly anyone read,
including a British one.
It really starts with Proudhon,
a name a sent around.
Pierre-Joseph Proudhon.
He was from the east of France,
from Besançon,
in the mountainous
Franche-Comté.
He believed that if you didn't
have the state,
the people could live pretty
much as with a little bit of
prosperity that they had,
a few chickens,
a little piece of land.
People tended to live like that
there.
It was a place where nobody had
very much but everybody had
enough to get along.
He writes the following.
It's in my lecture notes.
To be governed is to be
watched, inspected,
spied upon, directed,
law-driven, numbered,
regulated, enrolled,
indoctrinated,
preached at,
controlled, checked,
estimated, valued,
censored,
commanded by creatures who have
neither the right nor the wisdom
nor the virtue to do so.
To be governed at every
operation at every transaction,
noted, registered,
counted, taxed,
stamped, measured,
numbered, assessed,
licensed, authorized,
admonished, prevented,
forbidden, reformed,
corrected, punished,
under the pretext of public
utility in the name of the
general interest to be placed
under taxes, drilled,
fleeced,
exploited, monopolized,
extorted from,
squeezed, poached, and robbed.
At the slightest resistance or
the first word of complaint to
be repressed,
fired, vilified,
harassed,
hunted down,
abused, clubbed,
disarmed,
bound, choked,
imprisoned, judged,
condemned,
shot, deported,
sacrificed, sold,
betrayed,
and to crown all,
mocked, ridiculed,
derided, outraged, dishonored.
That is government.
That is its justice.
That is its morality.
He wrote a pamphlet in 1841
called What is Property?
His answer is,
"Property is theft."
He didn't mean that all
property was theft.
What he meant was too much
property was theft,
or unearned property was theft.
Proudhon had lots of influence
among some peasants,
but mostly artisans.
In the world, by the way,
that the great painter,
Gustave Courbet painted a lot,
in the area around
Besançon or Nantes,
lots of really marvelous
paintings of people at work,
the stone breakers and people
just working their guts out for
very little.
Proudhon, in 1848,
it's said he went down in Paris
and put a brick on a barricade
and threw up,
nauseated by the thought of
violence, of revolution.
His successors,
sort of the leaders of the
anarchist movements,
were Mikhail Bakunin,
an enormously tall, bearded,
heavy-drinking, heavy-eating,
heavy-sweating Russian noble,
a prince who was an anarchist
who said,
"The revolution will come.
It will come with a single
spark and all the hundreds of
millions of toilers,
the serfs will rise up,
and they will slay their social
betters,
and create this new brave world
based upon their village
harmonies."
He said, "Destruction is a
creative passion,"
entre guillemets.
Destruction is a creative
passion.
In 1848 he led police on a
merry chase.
He spent time in the Russian
slammer.
He escapes through Japan,
goes through the United States
and ends up back in London,
terrified people.
His image, this is before
photographs or photographs are
just starting out,
and there are photographs of
him.
He met Marx,
whom he hated,
and Marx hated him.
He thought that Marx was
ruining class struggle,
was ruining revolution by
preaching over and over again
about waiting for revolution.
Class-conscious workers.
What you need is peasants to
rise up as they had in
Pugachev's rebellion,
and all the other rebellions in
the early seventeenth and
eighteenth century.
He dies in the early 1870s,
a phenomenal character.
The other Russian,
a gentle man,
a geographer,
Peter Kropotkin,
K-R-O-P-O-T-K-I-N,
is in the book.
He wrote a pamphlet called
The Anarchist Morality.
When you get rid of the state,
people are basically good.
Anarchists believe that people
are good.
There's a tradition from
Rousseau, by the way,
there too.
Rousseau, who lived in the east
of France, or what would become
France, around Chambéry,
who believed in the primitive.
Anarchists believe that
primitive social relations and
even primitive ways of producing
things,
just associations you enter in
because you want to,
were the future.
Kropotkin, who at the end of
his life was once toasted by the
king of England,
and who had turned against the
Russian Revolution--he died in,
I think,
1921 or 1922.
He was terrified,
just disgusted by the Russian
Revolution, which was already
creating a centralized state.
That's what he hated.
He hated states.
"You must destroy the
state."
But he was a gentle man.
Yet he and a guy called Paul
Brousse,
you don't have to remember,
who became a socialist leader
and then went nuts later--that's
not a very clinical term,
but he had big problems
later--they create the term
"propaganda by the
deed."
What is a deed?
A deed is a bomb.
A deed is an attack.
It's the murder of an official.
The anarchists weren't the only
ones doing this stuff.
There was a Russian group,
briefly mentioned,
called Narodnaya Volya,
who believed in kind of a
hierarchical post-revolutionary
system.
What they wanted to do was set
out and kill officials.
But so did the anarchist
terrorists.
They killed officials,
one of which you've heard of
already.
You've probably heard of some
of the others.
President McKinley in 1901,
Buffalo, New York,
is killed by somebody who
received funds from an anarchist
organization in Patterson,
New Jersey, I think,
or is that Bresci?
Anyway, Bresci kills King
Umberto I of Italy,
another anarchist
assassination.
They kill five or six leaders
during this period of anarchist
heyday really,
the late nineteenth century.
King Umberto I of Italy said
that he considered assassination
a professional risk.
There were two attempts on his
life and the third one nails
him.
Alexander II,
who liberated the serfs,
is killed when he gets out of a
sled to look at a bomb that
doesn't work.
Elizabeth, the empress of
Austria-Hungary,
who couldn't stand Franz Joseph
and lived apart from him,
is assassinated as well.
But most anarchists were not
killers.
Now, if you think of American
history,
those of you who had Glenda's
course,
or David Blight's,
other people here,
you might know about Haymarket,
the Haymarket affair in the
1880s.
There they hanged four
anarchists who were called
les pendus in France.
They had enormous influence.
The les pendus were the
hanged, as they're swinging in
the breeze in a Chicago prison
yard.
They were anarchists and they
inspire someone like Emma
Goldman,
who was a Russian-Jewish
immigrant to the United States,
who becomes an important
American anarchist.
Anarchists set off to kill
policemen, or to kill heads of
state, or to kill generals;
propaganda by the deed,
the spark that will ignite this
revolution.
But the man you see before
you--and I have become today a
very modern man.
I want to tell you,
because this is my first try at
PowerPoint.
The person that you see before
you is the guy I've been
following around.
I got interested in him for two
reasons.
One is that he is the first,
really, along with a bombing at
an opera in Barcelona,
the Liceo to target ordinary
people.
To say that people of a social
class were guilty because they
were who they were.
The spark does not necessarily
have to be lit by killing a head
of a state.
Sadi Carnot,
who would get his in 1894 on
the Rue de la République
in Lyon, president of France.
He takes the decision to kill
ordinary people.
Lots of terrorists since then
have taken that decision.
A classic example is insurgents
in Punjab in India in the 1920s,
bombing officers' clubs.
There's a terrifying scene in
that fantastic,
but very difficult
movie--because of the torture
scene,
I can't even use it in the
French History course--The
Battle of Algiers.
You are with this woman who's
planting a bomb in a café
and she sees the people who are
going to die.
She sees babies with their
mothers.
She sees people having a drink
in the French community there.
She takes the decision to place
the bomb.
I believe that it kind of
started with this guy.
This is, again,
not somebody I admire.
I know him.
Everywhere he's lived I've been.
I guess if you're going to
write a book about somebody as a
prism on something or other,
it's good to pick somebody who
only lived to be twenty-one,
because it's a shorter book.
He was guillotined in May 1894.
Again, I do not admire him,
but I'm going to tell you about
him anyway.
With the help of PowerPoint!
How in the hell do I do this?
I've got to remember how to do
this.
All right.
That's Émile Henry.
His father was a
communard who was
condemned to death,
somebody who'd fought in the
Commune.
So, this guy is born in Spain.
His father contracted mercury
poisoning in Spain,
and comes back to France after
the amnesty and dies.
He has an older brother and a
younger brother.
What he does is,
on a day in 1894,
he sets out with a bomb and he
walks in the fancy boulevards
that, for him,
represent all of the class
differences between wealthy and
poor people,
center versus periphery and all
of that.
He goes down to the Café
Terminus, which is on your
right.
It's those awnings there near
the Gare Saint-Lazare.
I've had the rather odd
experience of twice,
once with friends and once with
my son,
having eaten in the restaurant
that my book subject blew up,
because it's still there,
and sitting at the same table.
He goes to four or five cafes,
but there are not enough
innocent people in them.
So, he goes to the Terminus
where there is a gypsy orchestra
playing, pays for two beers.
That seems a little odd,
anarchist paying for a beer,
because the right to theft was
something that they still
believed in, many of them,
not all.
Most were not terrorists,
remember that.
He goes into the Café
Terminus.
He gets a cigar.
He lights the fuse.
He throws it toward a
chandelier and it blows up,
killing one and wounding about
eighteen people.
That's not him.
This anarchist is called
Malatesta, who doesn't look
particularly scary there.
Émile Henry had gone
back to the Paris region.
His mother had a very pitiful
auberge.
This is the era of bomb attacks
in the early 1890s.
That's a marmite,
as bombs were sometimes called.
He became an anarchist.
His brother had already become
an anarchist.
To put yourself into the early
1890s in Paris,
ordinary people,
but not so much as the elites,
were terrified of anarchist
bombers.
Ravachol, a name I sent around,
who was a poor,
pathetic in many ways but
extremely poor guy who'd been
sent out to beg by his mother.
They had almost no money.
They're from a place called
Saint-Chamond,
near Saint-Étienne.
Ravachol was a counterfeiter
and finally a murderer.
He suffocates to death a hermit
who had a mini fortune hidden in
his bizarre cottage near
Saint-Étienne.
He escapes from the police and
he goes to Paris.
In 1891 police beat the hell
out of three anarchists in a
march, a rather one-sided brawl.
Two of them are condemned to
big-time sentences.
Ravachol decides to go and to
kill the prosecuting attorney.
He places a bomb,
not knowing where the apartment
was, and the bomb blows up.
Then he set other bombs, too.
After having done this,
he goes to a restaurant,
and he eats rather well,
and he engages a waiter in
conversation.
He tries to convince the waiter
to be an anarchist.
The waiter sees he has a scar
on his left hand,
Ravachol did.
Then he stupidly goes back
later and eats in the same
restaurant.
Instead of bringing the second
course, the waiter brings the
police.
After a tremendous struggle,
Ravachol is captured,
put on trial for his life,
and he memorably holds up--how
do you work this thing?--anyway,
he is guillotined.
He's really kind of a bastard.
More than that,
and he killed other people too,
probably.
But he finally is guillotined.
Two things happened,
not only in Paris but in other
places.
The people of means living in
the fancy quarters are extremely
frightened.
There are all sorts of death
threats that get sent around.
Ravachol, to those anarchist
terrorists, he becomes a martyr.
Look, here his head is framed
by the guillotine.
Ravachol, who had been betrayed
by an anarchist friend,
dies at age thirty-three.
Christ died at age
thirty-three,
betrayed by a friend.
So, he becomes this sort of,
for radical anarchists,
he becomes a vision of how life
should be.
There are songs called La
Ravachol.
There's another one called
The Dynamite Polka,
being sung.
Dynamite, from the point of
view of anarchists,
leveled the playing field.
They viewed dynamite rather as
the way in which muskets helped
end the domain of feudalism.
It levels the playing field.
Dynamite, after all,
was invented by whom?
By Nobel, as in the Nobel Prize.
So the people who support
dynamite in French are called
the dynamitards,
the dynamiters.
The Dynamite Polka.
In Montmartre,
where you have a lot of
anarchist writers and artists.
Pizarro is an anarchist.
The literary and art critic,
above all art,
Félix
Fénéon,
who was a friend of
Émile Henry,
is an anarchist as well.
So, it's into this world that
the young Émile Henry.
Here you go.
Here's this one.
I've read hundreds of these
things that said,
"You've always been hard
with your domestics.
You're going to be blown up.
Death to the riches."
There are hundreds of these
things.
They're sent all over Paris,
not just the fancy
neighborhoods.
There, hundreds and hundreds of
times, at the airports you hear
these explosions sometimes as
they blow up suitcases that
haven't been claimed.
That's the first known machine
that blows up suspect items,
including lots of bad
jokes--sardine cans with a
little bit of powder left in
them,
and that kind of thing.
It's in this world that Emile
Henry learns to hate,
and that he certainly does.
That's where his mom had her
auberge.
Ironically, it's near Euro
Disney now, but then it was a
village.
That's not the one.
It was up the street a little
bit.
I did follow him around,
you can see.
There's his mother there.
Up on the right is one of the
places he lived,
always around,
except for one occasion,
Montmartre.
That's his girlfriend.
He had unrequited love.
She had the disadvantage of
being married to another
anarchist.
He writes her clumsy poems.
He falls in love with her.
She blows him off.
But in the end,
she wanted to take full credit
before the press for having been
the lover of Émile Henry
after his deeds,
his bombs,
but he wasn't.
That's one of the places he
worked in Paris.
I love that.
That's a beautiful sign and
that company hasn't existed
since World War I.
But you can follow him around.
In 1892, Émile Henry,
two years earlier,
he had killed before.
There was a strike in the south
of France, glassworkers in
Camaux.
The third block on the left is
number eleven and that's where
the company is.
They found a bomb there placed
about 11:00 in the morning.
Right there.
That's not the way it looked
then.
I've gotten in there twice to
see where he placed the bomb.
My son gets a little tired.
"Dad, do we have to look
at another one of these
places?"
They find the bomb and they
carry it down to the police
station, which is still there.
It was a reversible bomb,
which means when the chemicals
run together,
boom!
It kills five people terribly,
five policeman and a secretary
among them.
Body parts all over the place.
Emile Henry,
that's one of the places he
lived.
He is eliminated from the list
of suspects because they said he
could not have gone on the two
errands his boss sent that day
from near the station of the
north,
down toward the center of
Paris,
then up toward the Arc de
Triomphe,
gone back to Montmartre and
gotten the bomb,
placed the bomb,
and gotten back in two hours
and fifteen minutes.
When he went on trial for his
life in 1894,
a detective said, "Yes,
he could have done that in two
hours and fifteen minutes."
So, being a bit of an
empiricist, I did it.
And I replaced tramway and
Omnibus with a bus and with a
Metro.
I never take cabs, but I took,
instead of a carriage--of
course I didn't take that--I
took a cab and I subtracted
eleven minutes when my cab
couldn't turn left on the Avenue
de l'Opéra.
He did it.
There's no question about it.
In fact, when they did the
reconstitution of this building,
he knew every single part of
this building.
He did it.
There's no question about it.
Why did he hate so?
Part of it again,
this is the theme we've talked
about before,
was the social geography of
Paris.
Everywhere he lived,
with one exception that you
just saw, was in people's Paris.
All of the facades are still
there.
That's where he lived on the
Rue Véron,
on the very top floor.
That's where the poor lived.
He gets the bomb there in 1892.
They hated Sacré-Coeur,
for reasons you already know.
It was a symbol of penance for
the Franco-Prussian War and
penance for the commune.
His father was one of the
people condemned to death,
who was lucky enough to get out
and not be executed.
In a Zola novel that's very
underappreciated called
Paris,
published in 1898,
it's about a priest who,
to take an REM song,
is "losing his
religion."
His brother is an anarchist,
Guillaume.
He has fantasies about blowing
this place up.
I think it's ugly as hell.
I once went with my wife to see
where they cast the huge bell
that would drive people nuts and
still does, called la Savoyarde.
But that bell wasn't there.
But as a symbol,
you can't walk around
Montmartre and not see it from
various places.
He becomes a terrorist because
the people that he sees around
him are very,
very poor,
and he convinces himself,
even though he's an
intellectual,
he's a bourgeois.
He could have gotten into the
École Polytechnique,
which is a super,
Grande École.
It's a big engineering school.
He's a great student.
He's an intellectual.
That's the other thing.
Besides picking "innocent
people."
All people are innocent,
but you know what I mean.
The other thing is he is not a
sad sack or a dangerous one like
Ravachol.
He is not a guy called
Vaillant,
who places a little,
teeny tack bomb and throws it
in the Chamber of Deputies to
call attention to the plight of
the poor,
and is guillotined.
The first person in the
nineteenth century guillotined
who did not kill somebody.
This guy goes out to kill.
There's a scene in an old
Balzac novel called--all Balzac
novels by definition are old,
obviously--Old Goriot,
Père Goriot,
in which Rastignac,
who was sort of this
down-and-out noble who wants to
make the big time in Paris by
sleeping with all the right
people.
After Goriot dies,
he's up in the northeast
quadrant of Paris at Père
Lachaise cemetery.
He waves his hand down toward
the fancy quarters,
down ironically near where
Café Terminus would be.
The fancy quarters,
even before there are
boulevards,
and he says the equivalent of,
"It's war between you and
me now, baby."
That's a rough translation,
but that's what he said.
Émile Henry,
walking around on the hills and
seeing people walk down to be
domestics,
because they couldn't afford to
take the tramway or the Omnibus,
horse-drawn carriages.
He waves his hand and says,
"It's war between you and
me, baby,
and I will ignite the spark
that kills you MFs right
away."
That's what he does.
When he walked out of his
apartment,
he looked down and happily he
didn't have to see the Tour
Montparnasse,
which hadn't been built after
huge payoffs in the early 1970s.
Disgusting!
But what he could see were
these symbols of capitalism,
the state, and the church.
What did he see?
He saw the Eiffel Tower,
which was five years old,
a symbol of the republic and
the bourgeois revolution,
as he saw it.
He sees the Pantheon,
where they buried all these
Napoleonic marshals who
basically got a lot of people
killed if they didn't get
themselves killed.
And he sees Notre Dame.
He says, "It's war between
you and me."
This is the façade.
I love this stuff.
The inside building where he
lived isn't there anymore.
Now it's kind of an area that's
a little bit sketchy.
There's a lot of drug dealing.
When I got myself into there,
I had to kind of--;I didn't
want to look like a plainclothes
policeman.
Do I risk looking like a
plainclothes policeman?
No.
I didn't want to look like a
tourist sort of slumming.
I don't look like that much,
either.
When I went by these guys who
were sort of hanging out there,
I said,
"Salut les
gars,"
or "Hi guys,
what's up?"
I got myself in there to see
where he once had lived.
The point of that is that you
can see what he saw.
That gate is exactly the same
as that day when he walked out
to kill for the second time.
His bomb that he threw into the
Terminus--this is back in 1894,
this is where we started.
It hit a chandelier and
exploded.
He said at his trial that he
threw it too low.
He should have thrown it higher;
it would have killed more
people.
Only one died.
He'd already killed five before.
People are terrified.
They run all over the place.
It was speculated that his was
sort of an indirect suicide,
because his unrequited love,
this lady who lived in the
Boulevard Voltaire,
whose name was Elisa.
But no, because he tries to
escape in order to kill again.
They chase him and they catch
him.
A barber helps catch him.
A controller on the tramway
hits him with the control
mechanism that punches tickets,
just like in the old days on
those things,
not that I ever was in a
horse-drawn carriage.
They get him and they take him.
He's arrested for murder,
Émile Henry,
and is put on trial.
That's where he's writing his
mother.
We know a lot about him,
because they kept all these
documents.
It was so fun doing this.
I love stuff like that.
His mother was devastated,
as you can well imagine.
She cannot believe that her
Émile could have done
this.
He was her pride and joy after
the death of the father.
Those of you who have been to
Paris will recognize this.
This is the Conciergerie.
This is where Louis XVI,
Danton, Robespierre,
Marie Antoinette,
and others awaited,
they put their head between the
little window,
as they used to say,
la petite
fenêtre, to be
guillotined.
It's also got one of the three
most magnificent gothic halls
anywhere in France.
His guards took notes every
single day about what he said
and the anarchist songs.
They want to prove that
somebody else was involved in
this.
There probably was somebody
else in the 1892 attack who
helped him close the bomb.
So, Emile Henry goes on trial
in April of 1894.
He makes the famous declaration
in which he says,
"You have hung us in
Chicago,"
Haymarket;
"You have garroted
us," that's slowly
strangling us,
"in Barcelona."
When Franco was croaking in
1975, they were garroting an
anarchist even at that time,
1975 in Barcelona.
"You have shot us in
Germany."
I don't know how they killed
them in Italy,
but, "You've killed us in
Italy."
He says, "You,
the bourgeois,
who are in this café,
you are not innocent.
It's because of you,
the petty bourgeois.
You support les
gros,"
the big ones,
"on every possible
occasion.
You forget about us when your
factory owners throw us out when
we can no longer work any
longer,
or women workers happy not to
have had to prostitute
themselves in order to pay their
rent and their husbands' rent by
the end of the month.
But what you can never do is
destroy anarchism.
Its roots are too deep."
On the 22^(nd) of May
1894--that's what I said about
writing a book about somebody
that doesn't live very long--he
is executed at Place Roquette in
Paris, which was,
by intent,
the place where the state meted
out justice,
right in the heart of
working-class Paris.
That was not an idle selection
of a space.
We have his notes up to the
very end of his life.
This guy, Deibler,
is the executioner.
Monsieur de Paris.
This is the executioner meting
out, in quotes,
"justice."
Public execution,
by the way, in France,
maybe I said this already,
was in 1936 at Versailles--the
last execution was in 1974.
I'm constantly asked by people
all sorts of political opinions
in France,
where executions,
public capital punishment is
repudiated by most everybody,
how that we still have it here.
This is not a political
diatribe, so I won't say
anything about that.
Anyway, Deibler,
his son was the last public
executioner, did the last public
execution back when.
There he is.
There's somebody else putting
their head through the little
window.
That's what I mean by that.
That's the equivalent of his
mug shot.
So, he was wrong about the
roots of anarchism being too
deep.
What clearly happens is that
there was a trial during that
same summer where they put a lot
of intellectuals on trial who
did nothing except to say that
they were anarchists or to
criticize the state.
What my book--it's really a
book also about state
terrorists.
It's about the overreaction of
states.
Our state is a good example of
that,
and the tendency to try to
denigrate anyone who doesn't
agree with us as being
terrorists,
whether they were or not.
The intellectuals,
the jury sees through it in
1894 and only a couple thieves
are condemned and them not to
death.
There's anarchists in 1968 in
Paris.
There's a band of anarchists in
about 1909,1910,
1911, that hold up stores with
most modern tools,
shotguns and things like that.
The anarchist attacks were over.
There was no question about
that.
That doesn't make Émile
Henry less interesting.
As an intellectual,
the cross-class kind of--you
see this in Middle-Eastern
terrorism, too.
My book is also about state
terrorists.
What stops anarchist attacks in
Spain is the fact that the
public becomes aware that the
police were hideously torturing
people who did not agree with
the politics of the State.
They were torturing them.
You see where one could go in a
political diatribe,
which this isn't.
In Italy when the state
overreacts, anarchist attacks
virtually end.
Now, anarchism does not end in
Spain.
It does not end also for
reasons that are perfectly clear
already in Buenos Aires.
There's still a huge anarchist
community of exiles from these
Western European countries from
all over the place living in
London,
ironically in one of the more
chi-chi parts of London which
was then very poor,
around Charlotte Street,
where you can't afford to have
a pint of beer anymore.
That's where they live.
So, he was wrong about that.
The roots of anarchism were too
great.
But the connection that I want
to make, obviously,
especially since this is being
filmed it's not the place to do
it,
but when states,
including our own, overreact,
what they tend to do is to lash
out in ways,
and imprison unjustly,
and torture,
and don't give legal rights.
What they do is tend to
increase the number of those
people who despise us.
If you look back,
and again the commune is not a
bad way of thinking about this,
somebody figured out that of
all the victims of terrorist
attacks,
no matter how you define them,
the ratio between victims of
overreaction by states to
victims of anarchist terror--and
I'm not apologizing for
anarchist terror.
I hate it.
I'm not apologizing for terror
of any kind.
I hate it.
But the ratio was 260:1.
I suppose there's a lesson to
be learned there somewhere.
But it was fun to follow Emile
Henry around,
even though I don't admire him,
and to try to give you a sense
of how people felt when they
hated in the 1890s.
Their answer was not the same
answer as socialists,
which are to take power mostly
through electoral processes,
but to smash the state by
blowing it up.
See you on Monday.